Sky News has seen the first
comprehensive analysis of patients
needing critical care the cause of
coronavirus and it shows why hospitals
are under such pressure the intensive
care national audit and Research Center
looked at 196 patients admitted to
intensive care in England Wales and
Northern Ireland the numbers steadily
increasing since the start of the month
the numbers are still relatively small
but there are some interesting trends
139 of them were male about 71% their
average age was 62 not as old as you
would expect in fact 10% were in their
40s 5% were in their 30s but it can
affect people who are even younger and
were perfectly healthy I had zero
symptoms I arrived home in the 16th of
March on Monday and by Tuesday I had
horrific shortness of breath and an
extremely heart temperature by Wednesday
it had exacerbated really struggling to
breathe insanely insanely high
temperature convulsions in bed due to my
body fighting the infection on Thursday
I phone an ambulance and I've and I've
been in hospital now for this is the
fifth day three quarters of the patients
needed mechanical ventilation to help
with their breathing in the first 24
hours of being admitted underlining the
importance of sourcing enough
ventilators in the coming weeks so how
did they do well 163 of the patients are
still in critical care 16 have died but
17 have recovered and have been
discharged there's more comprehensive
data on those 33 patients because dead
or alive they have technically completed
their treatment half of them spent nine
days in intensive care
underlining the pressure on beds and it
wasn't just help with their breathing
that they needed 79 percent required
basic cardiovascular support that could
include drug treatment or the insertion
of tubes into their blood vessels 18
percent needed more advanced cardiac
care such as a temporary pacemaker and
12 percent needed kidney dialysis these
are very
seriously ill patients needing expert
care and as the epidemic gets worse more
staff will need to be retrained to give
life-saving care to a growing number of
people